right now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week
first up closing the healthcare gap
affecting children across America this
week the Centers for Disease Control
released a new report highlighting some
of the health issues that our nation's
most vulnerable face and possible ways
to address the disparities in care here
now with more on the report a CBS News
contributor dr. taryn Derulo's Tara what
did this report seek to address exactly
well it's trying to address how do we
get our kids to reach their fullest
potential and that a lot of these health
disparities actually have the foundation
or are rooted in early childhood so
those first eight years are really
critical for setting the stage for what
kind of success a child has what kind of
health a child has how their learning
will develop and so stressors in early
life can affect children neurologically
metabolically immunologically
we're talking about things like poverty
things like instability in their home
life lack of quality education and that
can really create a trajectory for a
child so that they become at-risk or
vulnerable and so we know for example
that socioeconomic status is associated
with language development as early as 18
months that vocabulary in a
three-year-old will predict how well
they read in third grade which will then
go on to predict whether they graduate
from high school which then has effects
on chronic diseases so kids who don't
graduate from high school tend to have
more chronic diseases like diabetes so
all of these things are very important
and something that we just aren't early
with it didn't the report identify ways
to sort of address these vulnerable
children so they talked about trying to
pick this up early so that we can refer
kids early for intervention and they
talked about screening for health
disparities socially as well they talked
about identifying kids who may have
hearing issues developmental issues
motor issues and trying to get them
again initiated into treatment early on
and then they also talked about this
idea that just because you identify that
a child is vulnerable doesn't
necessarily mean that they will get into
a program because a lot of the programs
have strict eligibility criteria so what
we need is more programs like for
example what they reference a program
called helped me grow where there's
really kind of a one information line
that parents can call and really help a
child get
with the right program did this the
study look at what doctors specifically
and good knew because of what this
report is obviously about children but
it affects the parents well it did and
so again it placed a big role on doctors
for early identification and early
referral for treatment in particular
they also talked about behavioral issues
and mental health and so we know that in
this country about only 20% of kids with
behavioral issues are getting helped
mental service have mental health help
and so that needs to be addressed and
then they talked about a two-generation
approach basically means we're not just
targeting the child we have to target
the parents we have to look at the whole
family so screening and treating for
things like maternal depression teaching
parents about self-care for themselves
teaching parenting strategies if you
treat the whole family you're gonna do a
better job at helping the child down the
road they imprint on all the things that
we do our next topic the ongoing battle
against multiple sclerosis it's
debilitating debilitating disease that
impacts an estimated 400,000 Americans
and there is currently no cure the new
research at New York's Mount Sinai
Hospital is examining how diet can
potentially play a role in the fight
against MS our Tatara takes a closer
look we'll just go around and and hear
an update from everyone once a month
this pioneering group of MS patients
meets to get tips from a nutritionist
when grains are refined they're stripped
of this outer layer and share their
temptations it was craving hamburgers
I'm terrible the other day they had
lobster crabs and there was
just no way I was gonna test that off
neurologist Ilana Katz and is leading
one of the first clinical trials to
study the link between what we eat gut
bacteria and MS symptoms why did you
decide to investigate diet and it's
linked to ms the gut is actually kind of
a natural place to look and that's
because the immune system about 70% of
it lives inside the gut and has
far-reaching implications throughout the
rest of the body in ms inflammation
occurs when immune cells attack the
brain and spinal cord
this study is testing whether a dietary
intervention can reprogram the immune
system to slow down the assault on
itself so this right here is a very
typical looking spot for MS Karine
Providence and the other patients
enrolled in the trial are following a
strict Mediterranean style diet no
processed food dairy or meat but lots of
fruits vegetables and whole grains why
did you choose that type of diet we
think that those are anti-inflammatory
and we also think that they're neuro
protective symptoms like fatigue
difficulty walking vision problems and
cognitive changes can be severe and
disabling but it can take a very heavy
toll on patients I was really fearful
because you know I have a family have my
children I have my husband and I felt
like as if my life would just be over
with the help of medication Kareem is
still able to work nights as an oncology
nurse four years after her diagnosis
have a pleasant day for her sticking to
the diet is a small sacrifice for better
health no chocolate chip cookies no
dairy no vanilla ice cream that I love
so much but I mean if I can participate
in a diet that can change my life
give me longevity give me a piece of how
I was before I don't mind
well fascinating Tara how unusual is it
to approach treating MS through through
diet it is it is new but it's something
that's happening across a lot of
different fields in medicine you know
one of the things that came up when we
talk to these patients is giving them a
sense of control that's what this is
doing and for diseases like MS
they patients mentioned they may look
well on the outside to people people may
think they're not sick but they suffer
from things like inability to walk bowel
or bladder incontinence trouble with
their vision it really is or can be a
very crippling and disabling disease so
giving them something very small like
changing their diet allows them to feel
empowered just so important to set in
the piece of small sacrifice but it
makes a big difference a huge difference
all right finally using technology to
improve the lives of children with
cerebral palsy these children commonly
experience something called Crouch gait
it's due in part to abnormalities of the
hips knees or ankles and can impact
range of motion making basic things like
walking difficult a team of researchers
at Columbia University's Department of
engineering tested the use of a cable
driven robotic training device the
device applies force on the pelvis
research published in the journal
Science Robotics showed not only
improvements to posture but also
strengthening of the children's lower
limbs it's fascinating that robotics can
be used like this again it is and when
you think of the numbers about four out
of a thousand school-aged kids are
diagnosed with cerebral palsy and this
abnormal gait or abnormal walking can
lead to joint degeneration down the road
where we stand now we don't have a lot
of options physical therapy wise or
strengthening exercise to offer so
something like this could make a really
big impact
fascinating dr. tara Narula thanks